free hello and welcome to this video
playing back soon that's a new opponent
oh it's got a ton of games and never
play them interesting okay got the
London system we had a capture he has
the most critical move but let's not
play that often uhm Jung ok let's go
queen bee six okay here c4 and Queen bag
isn't that clear yeah I remember I
remember now it's also why I wanted to
take on deform play Bishop g4 instead
hmm that's a bit annoying okay it just
takes okay yeah this is just good for
black I mean I mean not like a huge
advantage but I have absolutely no
problems now so he goes for that Bishop
d1c to kind of trade so yeah let's see i
can go over here immediately or the a
kid doesn't it doesn't really let that
much if i do but but still am the night
is right on b6 always on the lookout for
night a4
yeah what is White's plan in this
position to be interesting to learn some
f34 maybe re for immediately seems to be
seems to be okay I'm happy to gain space
okay she give me all that space I'm
happy to take it I can even go e5 now in
this position but I ok that that's a bad
idea ok I'm sorry that wasn't nonsense
nonsense comment that you can just take
that doesn't make sense at all
yeah well it's very nice for blackjack
and try to improve my position while
white is just sitting around but to
actually improve it's not so easy some
kind of e five but it's hard to play
surprising I can take right but
surprised I in take I mean here he can
take a look g8 completely weird way of
phrasing things but what I meant is i
can let him take that was fitted my my
point I can't so going to take this
doesn't look bad right I really have a
hard time to understand what he's doing
here okay now i would like to get night
over to f5 let's do that
check the night comes over to f5 here we
go the key thing is I have night a for I
have night a 4 and the b2 pond jack is
the problem that's the whole problem
with whites position double time okay so
age 5 or not Sam h5 should be good I
cannot easily attack this 92 and so on
but that takes quite a while pin so i
can take you can go night f4 now that
it's not a problem i have this I have
this so let's see how this is plate now
Bishop 783 I guess so take that pawn or
is there a better way to do it
not probably probably okay on to just
grab this
now this is probably the safest get the
edge pawn I Scott night f4 now it
doesn't really matter much I can play
before light therefore be four takes
bishop f2 and I will win the remaining
pawns on most of them okay go back let's
get rid of that be pawn to get the deep
on and now if I before on it's also not
bad and keep that covered for Bishop e3
that's two points and them probably
going to get this as well okay it shoots
for night see to Vegas time whining
right I'm have to watch the time a
little bit let's run this pawn we should
have four th to check
then do this it's a bit fancy but I
think it's good check 26 seconds I have
their arch I've way to win this might
have to check check check Stanley knife
on the stalemate I am 11 seconds I
founder still me I really thought ok go
away and move the deep on I really
didn't see that it is a stalemate ah
quite funny after that game two not
witness kind of kind of kind of bad him
ok I am ok yeah it was a mysterious
gamer for someone with that rating
because white is just worse after 17 and
has to struggle and it's also been known
that the structure is just bad for what
so I was surprised this is actually the
point of white smooth water should be
the point that now you're ready to play
e-form um yeah I have a couple of ideas
i think i would have played this one
it's an interesting way to play
and this this kind of thing needs to eat
sooo interesting plane yeah but okay and
this is this is a well-known structure
that is just better for black wear white
has to suffer yeah and why did summary
when he just has less space and he was
basically just shuffling around after
g-form yeah like it's just clearly
better that's what it is chan and he has
the clear the worst pawn structure and
is sitting on those weaknesses and yeah
the way and when did was I mean maybe I
had some quicker wins but I think I
played in a way that was very very safe
let saya never giving him any kind of
play so I'm actually quite happy with I
did this how i did this technically
until I oops so we're delays here until
I ran into the stalemate yeah what I was
just thinking okay please no stalemate
that's good and just so it happened
check ideas or okay I'm in check check
check check it really is a stalemate
whatever whatever I do have to have to
just avoid asylum jack in fact this is
the made into work yeah maybe I should
have just taken a moment there with the
11 seconds and then consider it okay
anyway these kind of things they do
happen sometimes okay thanks for
watching